بدورها جددت حركه النهضه التونسيه دعوتها
لمقاطعه الانتخابات التشريعيه واقله
الحركه في بيان انها وضعت على قياس
الانقلاب وبادواته لتمكينه من الانفراد
بالسلطه وتكريس الاستبداد الفردي حسب وصف
بيان الحركه وراتان البرلمان الذي ستسفر
عنه الانتخابات سيكون اقرب الى دعم ما
تقرره سلطه الانقلاب ومن دون صلاحيه او
قدره على اداء دوره الحقيقي في التشريع
والرقابه بحسب وصف الحركه
وكان الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قد رفض
الانتقادات الامريكيه لتوسيعه سلطاته في
البلاد والقى باللوم على ما وصفها
بالاخبار الزائفه وقوى الاجنبيه لم يسميها
بسبب معارضتها لحكمه وفق تعبيره وقال سعيد
خلال اجتماع مع هيئه تحرير صحيفه الواشنطن
بوست ان هناك العديد من من وصفهم باعداء
الديمقراطيه في تونس يريدون بذل كل ما في
وسعهم لنصف الحياه الديمقراطيه
والاجتماعيه للبلاد